[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
are there any conflicts that need to be
clear at this point in time
there is any horizon so we need to move
on to the confirmation of
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
strategy
uh
[Music]
so i'm not sure that all counselors will
know
[Music]
so my role is i am the general manager
for tourism events
at great south which is the region's
regional development agency
yep i'm actually a poor girl which i
always say not just when i'm
going but everywhere else too i'm
proudly born and read and
my family is still in board on the board
of trustees before high school so still
have a lot to do with
with this community it's good to have
you
yeah thank you for the invitation event
strategy
yeah so i'll just i'm just going to take
five minutes today
i think i just want to firstly
acknowledge michelle
uh jim there's been a few people that
have been involved in the development of
this
strategy so we really appreciate the
staff have gotten time
you know there's a lot going on this
piece of work come out of the southland
regional development strategy
was being further mandated through the
south american destination strategy
and what it's pretty much saying is that
there's 1612 events in the region
but there's a whole lot of things that
we need to do to leverage the benefit of
these events
and to support the people delivering
them and this has been really made
important with covet
um because events have a couple of
different functions not just from our
building hotel beds and an economic
context but also from a well-being so
people need to have social interaction
and opportunities to to know
why they live here in that quality of
life so what the strategy does is it
sets
it um within what the first one we did
was an audit
where we basically found sixteen hundred
and twelve beds
um of interest was that two two-thirds
were held in the cargo and about
nine percent were held in zero uh so
that's just the number that doesn't
acknowledge the significance of your
needs
look i think probably if you all had a
chance to read this
what's important is that it was
multi-stakeholders
were involved to develop it and that is
important because while great staff
facilitated the development we're not
the only ones involved
in delivering against it um but as a
regional development agency obviously
you will ask us to do
some stuff as to the other eight
shareholders so we do have a key role
um but it also acknowledges a lot of the
good work and the events
and the expertise that's already out
there in the community
uh there's already implementation
underway but at the moment we're just
getting the councils and shareholders to
sign off
on the document just to make sure
there's that level of comfort
one of the things that we're doing that
will be of interest is that
with um the borders closed at the moment
events are actually really important for
driving domestic visitation
so what that means is that for us to be
able to market events
as part of how we promote the region
they actually need to be in certain
formats that we can do that
so for example digital footage or photos
to help promote it
so we've identified i think at the
moment like 31 events
and we're working with each of those
event organizers to just give them a
hand
um to help them get the right things to
help promote their event
and that's only at the event what's that
um it's up to each event
and i think if you're okay that's
probably announcing this
summary is any questions
thanks bobby yes so um
quite a lot of background going to
believe this
strategy together um so counselors do
you have any
questions or ideas you'd like to uh
to vote at this point in time bobby can
you just
give us a bit of a sense as to where
it's at with the other partners and
grabs out
with icc and southern literature so my
understanding is that it goes up to sdc
and icc today as well yep and
all the funders of events were involved
as well which was quite good because one
of the outcomes in here is around
streamlining funding processes for being
organizers so you don't
have life appliances and then looking
also economic
benefit of things so trying to have some
persistence or
methodologies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you think about recreational crafts
as well
yep through your worship yeah no that's
um this is just a guideline
i think once we get some of those people
together and they'll probably have a bit
more knowledge than us
because the other complicating thing is
that the government allocated through
the tourism recovery fund
50 million dollars towards events and
that was basically to say well we don't
have international visitors
let's drive dissertation and so
southland's been able to access about
1.2 million of that through
both and this thing is really important
because
what it's doing really is it's
turbocharging the implementation
so while this is a five year term on it
now that we've got that funding it
complements what the councils are
putting into great south what the other
funders are putting in
and it just means we can have a good
look at some of these things and maybe
identify more often
interesting to note i'm sure councils
have voted
seven years framework in the premier
events
there's three premier events identified
two of them based in google district
which is
um
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
okay
[Music]
uh to increase its input into
stage one which is the redevelopment of
the virtual museum
and doing that um but that decision
involved bringing forward
confusion stage two to get stage one
over the line underway which is now
uh there was a request from the council
for the report on
what was uh what is stage two uh its
timing
bear in mind that uh stage two was
always a little bit more hazy
in its definition
[Music]
stage two was
not having an absolute firm idea
of what that might involve in such a
good
month year and a half it has allowed the
number a little bit more further
that stated i believe there is a case
for not just the
council contribution to increase
slightly but it need be
the cost of the project increases i
think there's a moral uh
if that price increases with a more
design
um i believe the pg for
and secondly and again timing
um to emerge
so that's the plan of attacking which
this is really about
an early um indicator of what
we think we'll need to be sharing with
the account with the
community with the ltp but of course it
first needs to get counsellors
in principle that this is a significant
item for
engagement in march um
um we do have a very good indication of
costs through quantity surveys
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
inflation adjustment on run that was
agreed to in 2009 so essentially it's
two hundred thousand dollars that
was taken over one
[Music]
essentially what we're being asked for
as a council
amount of is into our long-term plan so
that we can have a conversation
[Music]
um
the heritage precinct development is a
significant one
in the life of this community and
it will be good
for discussions
um on the 17th of november we allocate a
bit more than 400 thousand
if you look at the minutes
i think it's 450 000.
now just the questions have been going
forward we're having their
estimates just before christmas for the
long-term plan
would be nice to sort of have that first
and then
have this second but um
it's come up now and you want to have to
put into the long-term plan it would
be nice to know where that money's
coming from whether it's loan funded
or whether we could get it from capital
optimization selling
council assets to actually raise our
money have a plan for where we can get
that money
i'm just wondering whether we put a tag
on it that we actually we will use
loan money to fill the gap but we need
to fill it with
sale of assets to pay for it and i guess
now
[Music]
[Music]
i mean um this is just about
advancing this is in
we'd like response see report on stage
two
and we'd like to survive counselling we
would like to
have a reasonably soon now i thought
we'll put up here now so that
before we get into
um
[Music]
should we not uh invest that money
um personally on favor of it we often
talk about business activity promoting
business activity
promoting the council promoting the
district and this is one way of doing it
we do know
we're going to get nothing now i'll say
that as a person who doesn't live in the
town
[Music]
[Music]
will
[Music]
[Music]
that's going to give us a bit more of an
idea of exactly where we are now we've
just committed 1.3 million to the
library james coming uh
communion center upgrade which which
has you know had to happen um you know
as governors of the
gdc bank basically we have to be
fiscally responsible for
what happens here and and just right at
the moment
i'm not at all
i am in favor of this project the
roadblock i've seen what's happening
it's a great idea but just right at this
present time i believe we need a whole
lot until we have our first workshop
steve if i may ask you um
wednesday when's the date that we have
to
notify for ltp what's the last
so can we hold this over till february
or even very much
um
[Music]
our horses um
this may all become quite
all you're starting off on is inclusion
based on financial challenges
we're proposing not to receive
projections
but it wouldn't bother me if you wanted
to describe this until
you think i've talked um i'm not sure
what our council meeting
is but we wouldn't by early february we
need to have a pretty good idea
about where our financials is
[Music]
[Music]
report that it was 475 that was in the
long-term
so the figures are just a little bit
confusing
um
community that had this conversation and
it's already been in the media which is
great
and i guess my only question through you
was as realism on that number um
you know councils and this council have
been guilty in the past between numbers
and ltps that
are unrealistic and we find ourselves um
having supposed budget overruns which in
fact
are thrust upon us so keen to say
getting the ltv
conversation to carry but providing that
number is
hand on the heart in terms of what we
can get so
what are the risks on that 340 speed
around
the council's contribution obviously
other funding falls over
tends to fall back on council um the qs
numbers are obviously in so there could
be some sort of
apart from that is there anything else
i'm not saying
let's bring your question um no i don't
think so
there might be
the landscape has changed earlier with
paper 19 but on the last time
again when are we planning on
strategically having that conversation
well actually uh innovation is that's
quite recent
uh stage one is thanks to powerful
engagement questions that
you need to say well just give us a
moment to expand
[Music]
that might be um problem um whether they
agree as much loss in terms of perhaps a
change of approach but there is an
increase in scope or cost approaching
i do believe there's a strong model
um
[Music]
is
um
the way they
[Music]
so one last question on that so the 340
salmon council doesn't assume that
that was worthwhile
that was the 200 which was allocated
so we really have a change
[Music]
um
[Music]
their precinct absolutely
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
in regard to obviously uh looking at the
the time frame when we talk about
the funding that that's coming through
here starting in 2007 and obviously
there's been
13 or 14 years getting to this point
here
and being the first man counsellors to
realize that
we do have to have that investment and
it's been a long road to get to this
point
i think
uh
you put forward your proposals there's
an expectation that you are ready
and you get off uh this is uh
as a result of a bit and a direct
invitation
for stage two as well um so no i don't
believe we'll be
uh at all um and we're entitled as the
pictures changed communities
three four
[Music]
um
thank you uh always available
thank you guys motion's carrier thank
you councillors
we'll move on then to um playground
consultation and we have a report
from our parks and direct manager um
reporting on some um conversations that
we have
consultations in space
um
um
the proposal
one pertinent point that came out from
a number of those that verbally
submitted was the value that the people
the community place upon
[Music]
um
all three that will move through
playgrounds
from brown street and
place and also plus
brown streets
increase and change within existing
budgets to play opportunities there
to come for the older children given
that the new playground
at uh pittsburgh the weyland park does
cater for small children
pretty much the underrated really so
if we can update sword stream facilities
[Music]
the consultations occurred with that
part of town
so i guess i have a question around is
that the best
or good in terms of its locations that's
at the southern end of town
it's not centrally located and if we are
going to invest it's fun to allow
playground to children is that the best
locality and it seems to be centralized
consultation at that end and you look
for
um
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
going through that area
[Music]
could you take into consideration the
fact that there are a number of young
people and until probably 13 plus
that are currently really engaged in
basketball
in the community but they don't have a
public space
in which to do that and i just wanted i
don't know
about a short course or anything like
that whether that allows
that space but you know something like
that so that they can take
um
to ask a question of man uh where is
that is that water pipe and we're on the
street right through the middle of that
uh it's a snowball
yeah i would leave that as a playground
sword streak
while i was doing it i would cut the
playground down
to a reasonably small area still leave a
playground there but cut out and put two
sections in there to as
asset optimization that area is 745
square meter
2 600 square meter sections could be cut
out
still leave a a reasonable playground
for children to
play on and mower place
is 2158 square meters of the chop
corners of it centralize the path
and put in two sections there and still
leave
a nice green area in the middle
of something around seven eight hundred
square meters which is a
column of a section uh
we could keep up getting the people what
they
need and generate some income for
councils
asset optimization and still leaving
good
good green areas in those areas to play
so that's that's how i would manage it
as i was making the decisions today
that's what would happen finish thank
you
the submissions and the three people
that
uh three people that are five turned up
they were very they are keeping their
playgrounds down in that area
especially ford street
um
it was actually being on so uh on
the evening i would like to move that we
adopt the recommendations
i think these places spaces green spaces
are very important particularly
now um because you did see
quite a few people and children playing
in these parks
through lockdown period and i think
there are some lower social
families that can't afford to go to
baltimore park
or spain so um
as well and i i
[Music]
for you and if you're gonna leave a
playground you probably leave sword
street
and um definitely know a place you're
actually got about a 10 hectare reserve
right beside it now
however 10 i could reserve one deciding
so you've got two
sections that could be actually taken
there and have your walkway in between
and then you could actually develop some
of the paddock next door that's only
been leased for grazing
to actually is develop into whatever
we're going to develop
we've got acres of it just right there
so there is two sections that are quite
valuable
um the maryland place i would like to
see where the actual pipeline is
it should be able to be easily located
onto that map and see if there is
ability to take a section off that as
well
because um you know if the pipeline is
down to one side
uh there's plenty of room for a section
to be taken there
and i would oppose the option a
here
okay so um does anybody else want to
come to council really
and then council days thank you thank
you worship um i think
the lower place is
[Music]
suggestion
can take
12 months depending on the amount of
submissions
received and the
depression of the submitters
that can draw out quite a little process
to see it right through the conclusion
and noted that that ultimately would
need the sign of
the minister of conversation as well
just another question
so if
[Music]
[Music]
okay thank you
[Music]
is
at the time for a reserve and i think
morally we have
a duty to think about that when we're
making decisions
submitter if he did that we wouldn't put
the bridge across so i think there were
more
gangs submissions on the bridge and
moved forward
so we're going to go that way the bridge
is off the agenda
[Music]
yeah so we've discovered the bridge
so what's going to make up our mind is
what you think is the best long-term
uh result of transportation that's um
[Music]
talking about the access to the reserve
um there is still very good taxes
through
time street it goes straight into the
reserve so you don't actually need
three three accesses to their reserve
yeah
yeah just just thinking there's a bit of
theme tonight around
asset optimization and focusing on this
i'm just wondering if there's a place
for it and going forward for a working
group of counselors to look at
surplus assets or perceive circumstances
in the community
and take a a measured approach in terms
of moving forward
and whether this is the time to move in
direction or not might be guided by you
but i think it's
[Laughter]
and it's something that does crop up
from time to time so
probably we should be um considering all
the potential options out there
um and give it a few consideration of
time to
work through what the challenges might
be so anyway we have a motion
on the table recently now which is
effectively
option a as
laid out in a report for you
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
held on 23rd in november
just a couple of three items on
on the agenda but it's there for
our receipt
and uh
[Music]
um
just uh just a bit of explanation around
the community plan
um
um
over the last few years and most of
those actions
to
um
the board expressed that they had an
effort to do so but
what they wanted to do is explore and
shop what that might look like
um so the um that i provided simply send
out some principles they might want to
follow
some information that they want to
gather and starting their processes
excellent i think that's great um
so going forward will you
help them in that discussion so um
just going into
emergency committee for a particular
period of time
to make those decisions on behalf of the
council
and that the standard
i mean for the next
[Music]
just to make sure that the final
between the last council meeting and
christmas
[Music]
[Music]
three members
and two other councillors
i guess it's pretty important that those
councils
there's a good chance that they will
give up those
[Music]
and myself it's being nominated for
the emergency committee um
somebody had to move in that direction
council grant thank you
secondary council member now for the
emotionalized labour please say hi
yes the motions
[Music]
and i'm assuming
[Music]
and hopefully the acoustics
[Music]
perhaps it's me
okay is there going to be an opening for
the new building
uh yes i had that on my list to talk to
the chief executive about but i think we
should have one
and i think we need to involve the
public and that as much as we possibly
can
um
okay somebody like to move the adoption
off their
leadership counselor secretary
councillor
now thank you no discussion i'll put the
emotional license
please thanks the nation's carried
[Music]
[Music]
manager just giving us an update on
health and safety
any questions from councillors
[Music]
um project performance reports um
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay open for discussion counselors any
questions
if not with somebody like tonight we'll
do the
[Music]
cue council secretary
dixon thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tour through the building last friday
and it does look particularly good and
it just
looks like a new build um and very
spacious
so looking forward to moving in there
are a few
um
um
just on the contingency sums that were
in that budget
um is this i haven't got signal reported
friday but
a contingency sums fully drawn um on the
project because it was
from recollection about 30 000 in the ff
area
as a contingency i haven't seen the last
update as to
how much is left right but
i don't think a lot but i haven't had
an update to the minute
unfortunately do get
people who present in pretty accurate
tones moves and we've noticed
increasedness so it's a real health and
safety issue that we need to make sure
that we've got something for
so that we can react and quickly
is there one in the council chamber
you can request i
[Music]
is
[Music]
um agitated people as i know in my
previous film that was very helpful
um
um
the um gave uh months ago to
keep you up to date on a regular basis
um i can't report that today the
southern europe forum
endorsed the report and the rest of
but um the new year promises to be
i think uh one of some revelation in
terms of
the government's at the time
the extent of reform and pace in which
it
any questions
um
so that period
they're going to be um they're going to
talk to us about what's
the public or they're going to talk to
the council what's going to happen or
just going to come
it's kind of like a trade
and that's owned by the clutha district
and they're putting a new plant in
and they're noting that 65 of their
people
in that scheme are in the gore district
council
they wondered if they had any money
spare money from your funding
various sources from time to time
and there'll be um
engagement with council with those
communities but i think it might be more
of a runaway
[Music]
councilman thank you elizabeth
well against the motion is carried i
think that brings us to the
end of the open agenda